Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans « Septante Minutes Avec ». Salut, comme vous avez pu le remarquer, y a pas eu d'épisode il y a deux semaines.
Toutes mes excuses pour ça. J'ai pas su tenir promesse. Le podcast fête bientôt ses 12 mois et du coup, ça me donne l'occasion de comprendre pourquoi de nombreux médias arrêtent leurs activités en été.
C'est-à-dire qu'en gros, y a un paquet d'invités qui ont accepté l'invitation, mais qui m'ont gentiment répondu
qu'ils étaient absolument pas dispo avant septembre et qu'ils préféraient se dorer au soleil plutôt que de passer 70 minutes avec moi.
Ce qui est plutôt compréhensible. Du coup, y aura quelques annonces à la fin de l'épisode sur la suite et comment ça va se passer.
Aujourd'hui, je reçois Martine Simonis, qui est un petit peu la maman de tous les journalistes belges francophones, puisqu'elle est la secrétaire générale de l'AJP, l'Association des journalistes professionnels.
Et on parle ensemble du paysage journalistique belge, de la situation des femmes journalistes, qui sont très minoritaires.
On parle de déontologie et de précarité de l'emploi et de plein d'autres choses. J'étais malade le jour de cette interview.
On m'entend même tousser de temps en temps, et j'espère vraiment que ça n'affecte pas trop la qualité des questions.
C'est parti. Bonjour à tous, je suis aujourd'hui au siège de l'AJP avec ma voix rauque, mais pas seulement puisque je suis également rejoint par Martine Simonis.
Martine Simonis bonjour.
Bonjour.
Tu es secrétaire générale de l'AJP, l'Association des journalistes professionnels.
Tu es une juriste spécialisée en droit social, en droit des médias et en droit d'auteur,
et tu es à l'origine de projets comme le Conseil de déontologie journalistique, le Fonds pour le journalisme ou la Société des auteurs journalistes.
Donc, je le disais, tu n'es pas journaliste toi-même, tu es juriste et pourtant, on te sent très investie autour des questions liées au journalisme.
Comment est-ce que tu expliques ça, cet investissement ?
Oui donc moi, j'ai fait des études de droit et pas de journalisme. Et quand j'ai choisi ces études de droit, je les ai choisies un peu par défaut.
Je voulais pas faire des études scientifiques ou mathématiques. Je voulais même pas de statistiques, j'aime pas les chiffres.
Et donc il restait les romanes, le journalisme ou le droit. Et dans le journalisme à l'époque, donc moi, j'ai fait mes études dans les années 80.
À l'époque, y avait déjà de la précarité et du chômage. En romane aussi pour les profs. Y avait des profs au chômage à l'époque, c'est plus le cas maintenant.
Et donc j'ai fait le droit, mais j'ai toujours été intéressée par les médias, par la presse. Je me suis toujours informée.
Du plus loin que je m'en souvienne, j'ai toujours lu un journal. Voilà, et puis quand j'ai été engagée à l'association, c'était mon deuxième boulot après un boulot dans une maison d'édition. Je me
suis dit : « Bon voilà, moi, je vais rester cinq ans ici et puis je ferai autre chose à nouveau après ». Et puis en fait, j'ai tellement fait évoluer la fonction, j'ai fait évoluer l'association et puis j'ai créé
tellement de projets que j'avais l'impression de changer de métier tout le temps.
Et ça, moi, j'aime pas quand ça stagne. J'aime bien quand les choses bougent et voilà. Donc, je me suis investie complètement.
C'est aussi un métier où j'ai rencontré-
Forcément oui
...vraiment de personnes intéressantes.
On reviendra sur ce que tu disais y a un instant sur la précarité dans le secteur du journalisme. Ça, on en parlera certainement.
Mais juste avant de se lancer au cœur du sujet, est-ce que tu peux nous rappeler un petit peu ce que c'est, l'AJP, l'Association des journalistes professionnels ?
Qu'est-ce que, c'est quoi votre rôle ? Vous êtes une union professionnelle, c'est ça ?
Oui, c'est ça. Donc c'est d'abord faire une réponse ni, ni. On n'est ni un syndicat ni une ASBL.
C'est ça.
On est une union professionnelle. Les unions professionnelles, c'est en fait un statut juridique qui existe toujours en droit belge et qui, au départ, avait été prévu pour les syndicats, mais qui n'en ont pas voulu
parce qu'ils voulaient pas avoir de statut juridique.
Et donc certaines professions se sont organisées au sein d'unions professionnelles. Il y a une union professionnelle des magistrats, une union professionnelle des kinésithérapeutes, voilà.
Il y a aussi une union professionnelle des journalistes qui, ben elle est née en fait en 1886. Donc c'est vraiment une très vieille-
Ouais, c'est ça.
C'est une très vieille dame hein. Et avec différents changements de structure. Au départ, elle regroupait les employeurs et les journalistes de façon indifférenciée.
Et puis elle a évolué en se scindant, d'un côté les travailleurs, d'un côté les employeurs. Et puis elle s'est à nouveau scindée à la fin des années 90 en raison de la fédéralisation du pays.
Mh.
Et donc en fait, y a trois unions professionnelles des journalistes : une nationale qui s'appelle AGJPB, dont je suis la secrétaire nationale aussi, une francophone et germanophone qui s'appelle l'AJP,
et une néerlandophone, flamande, qui s'appelle la VVJ.
Ça concerne alors les journalistes. Et alors après ça, les employeurs sont encore...
Ah oui, eux, ils ont créé leur propre fédération. Y a une fédération pour-
Oui. Et donc du coup-
Les médias de presse quotidienne, etc. Donc ils se sont organisés de leur côté.
Et donc tu disais, vous n'êtes pas un syndicat. C'est quoi alors la différence entre une union professionnelle et un syndicat exactement ? Qu'est-ce que-
Alors-
En quoi est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un syndicat ?
Parce qu'en Belgique, on peut pas créer de syndicats. En Belgique, y a ce qu'on appelle un closed shop.
Uhuh.
Et pour être un syndicat, il faut affilier au moins 50 000 travailleurs sur base interprofessionnelle.
D'accord. Et vous êtes trop petits.
Et nous, on est 5 000 en Belgique sur base professionnelle. Si on était en France, on pourrait dire qu'on est un syndicat.
Mais la législation belge est telle qu'elle a mis un closed shop. Donc autrement dit, on peut plus créer de syndicats en Belgique et seuls les syndicats existants sont reconnus.
Ce qui nous empêche pas d'avoir des activités syndicales-
Mh
...parce que ça, on les a toujours eues. Donc en fait, les journalistes, traditionnellement, sont très peu syndiqués.
Et c'est logique hein, ça tient à leur indépendance. Ils veulent pas entrer dans des structures qui sont politiquement marquées
ou philosophiquement marquées, et donc ils préfèrent garder, ouais, de la distance par rapport à un syndicat ou à un pilier.
Et comme ils sont pas syndiqués, habituellement, ils sont membres de l'union professionnelle. Nous, on affilie 90 % des journalistes sur base volontaire, donc on a un taux d'affiliation extraordinaire.
Et pour les journalistes, en tout cas en presse écrite, on a de l'activité syndicale. Ça veut dire qu'on négocie pour eux des conventions collectives dans les entreprises, avec ou sans les syndicats.
Donc tu dirais que, voilà, le statut de syndicat, voilà, vous échappe pour des raisons un petit peu techniques, mais vous n'êtes pas sanctionnés.
Vous ne perdez pas d'opportunités parce que vous n'avez pas ce titre de syndicat.
Si, parce que je pense que si on était un syndicat, on serait beaucoup plus présent dans l'audiovisuel, on serait beaucoup plus présent dans les petites structures.
En fait, comme on n'a pas la législation derrière nous qui nous impose, les syndicats, ils ont ça, ils sont légitimes par la loi.
Nous, on doit être légitimes par autre chose. Alors, on est légitimes par notre taux d'affiliation, on est légitimes par notre action, par notre histoire.
Mais il faut à chaque fois, et je dirais quasi à chaque génération de journalistes,
quasi à nouveau prouver cette légitimité, leur montrer qu'on est légitimes et que c'est normal qu'on aille négocier pour eux ou à leur place ou qu'on les représente.
Mh, mh. Ok.
Donc si, on perd des opportunités, je pense, oui.
Ok, donc y a plusieurs facteurs qui entrent en jeu. Donc d'une part, ce que tu disais, le closed shop, le fait que le marché des syndicats est fermé.
Et d'autre part, ce que tu disais, c'est, voilà, les journalistes tiennent à avoir une certaine indépendance. Tu disais, ils ne veulent pas forcément se marquer comme appartenant à un pilier.
Et j'ai un petit peu tiqué quand tu as dit ça, puisque à mes yeux,
je, bon ça, ça s'effrite de plus en plus les années passant, mais pendant longtemps, on pouvait dire : « Tiens, tel journal fait partie du pilier catholique, tel journal fait partie du pilier libéral.
» Donc, dès le moment où on travaille pour un journal qui est marqué par un pilier, dans cette Belgique polarisée, pourquoi pas s'inscrire au syndicat qui va avec ce pilier ?
Oui, pourquoi pas ? Et il reste beaucoup de traces de ça. Donc, il y a certains journaux, comme par exemple les journaux du groupe Rossel, où il y a que le syndicat socialiste qui est présent.
Donc la CNE ou la CSC ne rentre pas chez Rossel parce que ça a toujours été des journaux anticatholiques, anticléricaux, des journaux de libre pensée, etc.
Et donc il reste des traces de ça. Et, mais je dirais de moins en moins.
Oui, ça s'effrite hein.
On a assisté pendant tout le XXᵉ siècle à la disparition de la presse d'opinion. Hein, des journaux comme La Wallonie, Le Drapeau rouge, tous ceux qui étaient très marqués, très ancrés dans une tendance politique ont fini par disparaître.
La dernière tentative, c'est la création du journal Le Matin. Je sais pas si vous ou tu te souviens de ça, mais c'est-
Ben voilà, c'était dans les années-
Quand tu dis Le Matin, moi, je pense à, il y a un journal qui s'appelle comme ça en Suisse, non ?
Oui, mais il y a eu un journal en Belgique qui s'appelait Le Matin et qui était lié de près ou de loin au syndicat FGTB.
Bon, il a fini aussi par disparaître. La raison n'étant beaucoup plus un modèle économique qui ne fonctionnait pas que...
Mais voilà, donc la presse d'opinion,
on en a quasi plus qui se revendique comme telle, d'être de la presse d'opinion. Donc, on retrouve en fait dans les journaux pas mal de pluralisme, même si on sait que L'Écho est plus à droite, que Le Soir et La Libre, peut-être plus un peu
du côté catholique, mais tout ça est en train de s'estomper.
C'est ça.
Et les journalistes ne veulent pas, que ce soit en presse écrite ou que ce soit à la RTBF, parce que ça revient continuellement par rapport aux journalistes de la RTBF, les journalistes ne veulent pas être assignés à une tendance politique.
Ils veulent leur indépendance. Ce qui les empêche pas d'être des citoyens, ça les empêche pas de voter, ça les empêche pas d'avoir des opinions,
mais en fait, leur travail consiste à pouvoir se détacher de cela et traiter l'information avec en tout cas le respect des faits.
Donc quand tu observes un petit peu la cohorte de journalistes qui sont inscrits ici à l'AJP, est-ce que la population des journalistes inscrits à l'AJP est représentative de la population en général ?
Ou bien est-ce qu'on observe, ben surtout, je sais pas moi, des cadres supérieurs, des personnes, plutôt des hommes que des femmes ?
Je ne sais pas. Est-ce que tu as le sentiment que-
Ah oui, comme ça. Oui, donc, ben ça tombe bien parce qu'on vient de collaborer à une étude universitaire qui a été faite par l'ULB, par l'Université de Gand, et qui s'appelle Portrait des journalistes belges.
Ah ben voilà.
Et donc on sait. Enfin, on a un portrait des journalistes belges. Donc le journaliste belge, c'est plutôt un homme.
Ok.
Donc on a 30 à 35 % de femmes dans la profession.
Ok, c'est peu.
Ce qui est peu.
Oui.
Ce qui est peu et qui coupe les ailes à un canard répandu du type : « La profession est féminisée, c'est pour ça qu'elle est paupérisée », blabla.
Ce discours qu'on entend très régulièrement-
Ok
...et qui est donc faux, en l'occurrence. Elle est paupérisée, mais elle n'est pas féminisée. Donc c'est plutôt un homme.
C'est un homme blanc.
Ok.
On a très peu de diversité d'origine dans la profession. C'est un homme qui est issu d'un milieu moyennement aisé.
Donc c'est pas les couches supérieures qui fournissent les journalistes, pas nécessairement. Moyennement aisé.
Il est dans trois quarts des cas universitaires. Alors quand on demande aux journalistes, ça, ça intéresse toujours tout le monde, si c'est plutôt quelqu'un de gauche ou de droite.
Voilà, oui. J'allais en parler, oui.
En fait, les journalistes du côté francophone se positionnent à l'identique de la population francophone.
Donc là, on a vraiment une ressemblance. Donc-
C'est ça.
Un peu à gauche.
Si on fait le même test en Flandre, on voit des journalistes un peu plus à droite alors ?
Eh bien non, il y a pas tellement de différence. Et c'est ça qui est étonnant, parce que là, ça veut dire que la population journalistique et la population flamande, il y a quand même un,
je vais pas dire un grand écart, mais un écart plus grand.
C'est ça.
Y a pas la même correspondance. Et en fait, la population journalistique se comporte en Flandre et à Bruxelles et en Wallonie de la même manière, donc sur le positionnement de type politique.
Donc presque indépendamment de là d'où on vient, si on est journaliste, on est, en général, un peu plus à gauche que la population-
Oui, et alors ça, c'est difficile à expliquer parce qu'on n'a pas de cause, enfin, on n'a pas de cause à ça.
Une des hypothèses d'explication, c'est peut-être que pour être journaliste, il faut avoir non seulement une curiosité pour la société, mais peut-être un engagement.
L'engagement pour le journaliste étant de s'intéresser à ce qui se passe autour de lui, de--
et donc c'est nécessairement, je pense, être dans une démarche qui est une démarche peut-être de type un peu plus collectif, un peu plus solidaire, un peu plus intéressée à ce qui se passe autour de soi, un peu moins égoïste.
Des choses que l'on rattacherait plus à, voilà, l'égoïsme, on le rattacherait plus à une tendance droite, extrême droite et l'altruisme à une tendance gauche.
Voilà, c'est une des pistes d'explication. Je dis pas qu'elle tient, mais de toute façon, on n'en a pas d'autres jusque-là, donc prenons cette-
Mais ça, ça se tient. Et alors donc pour revenir à ce qu'on disait il y a un instant sur la faible présence des femmes dans le secteur journalistique, ton analyse de ça, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Comment est-ce que tu expliques le fait qu'il n'y ait que 30 % de journalistes femmes ?
Alors ça, c'est pour nous maintenant un peu plus clair parce qu'on a fait, donc je vous ai parlé de l'étude portrait, mais on a fait une autre étude quasi en même temps avec l'ULB, l'Université de Mons.
Et cette autre étude, en fait, permet de voir, parce que c'était la question qui était posée au départ : pourquoi y a si peu de femmes dans la profession en Belgique ?
D'autant qu'on sait que dans les études de journalisme, dans les écoles de journalisme, y a 70 % d'étudiantes et 30 % d'étudiants.
Donc, on a, en fait, au final, la proportion sur le marché de l'emploi, elle se renverse puisqu'on se retrouve avec 35 % de femmes alors qu'elles étaient 70 % pendant les études. Donc-
Mystère.
Alors nous, on s'est dit : où vont les femmes et pourquoi ne vont-elles pas dans la profession ? Ou si elles y vont, est-ce qu'elles en sortent plus rapidement ?
Et en fait, c'est ça. Donc quand on regarde l'entrée dans la profession, les jeunes journalistes, on a une parité 50-50.
Ça veut dire qu'on a déjà perdu des femmes hein, puisqu'elles étaient 70 %. Donc là, elles sont à 50-50. Et ce que l'on voit, c'est qu'au fur et à mesure qu'elles vont avancer dans la carrière, elles vont sortir.
Et elles vont sortir plus massivement que les hommes. Les hommes sortent aussi, tout le monde ne reste pas, mais les femmes vont sortir et elles sortent massivement vers l'âge de 35 ans,
qui est en fait l'âge pour une femme où y a des choix de vie qui vont s'imposer, qu'on est obligé de faire : une famille, pas de famille, un conjoint, pas de conjoint.
Voilà, il y a aussi une horloge biologique qui impose des choix aux femmes qui ne les impose pas nécessairement ou pas comme ça aux hommes.
Et donc on se rend compte quand on creuse la raison pour laquelle les femmes sortent massivement, ça, c'est les chiffres qui le montrent, de la profession vers 35 ans, qu'il y a plein de choses qui jouent.
Et c'est ça qu'on a analysé dans cette étude. C'est qu'est-ce qui fait qu'elles s'en vont. D'abord, il y a la charge mentale.
Je sais que c'est un concept un peu à la mode, mais la charge mentale, les hommes l'ont aussi, mais ils ont pas la même charge mentale que les femmes journalistes.
Et ça, on le voit parce qu'on a fait des focus groups pour lesquels il y avait des questions sur la charge mentale. On voit vraiment que les choses se présentent autrement pour les hommes et les femmes.
Il y a la chronophagie du métier ajoutée à la charge mentale et il y a un troisième élément qu'on sous-estimait sans doute, qui est la prégnance du sexisme dans la profession.
Et donc justement, la question que j'avais envie de poser, c'est un petit peu la spécificité du métier de journaliste par rapport à tout ça.
Donc tu disais la chronophagie du métier, ça, c'est clair que c'est très particulier quand on est journaliste.
La question de la charge mentale, de qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on est une femme de 35 ans, etc.
Ça concerne un petit peu,
ben, toutes les Belges. Et donc, mais tu sembles dire spécifiquement, en plus de tout ça, dans le secteur du journalisme, un certain sexisme ambiant, qui pèse aussi dans la balance.
Oui, une profession qui est absolument pas accueillante pour les femmes en termes de conciliation vie privée, vie professionnelle-
D'accord.
...ni pour les hommes, ni pour les femmes d'ailleurs. Mais dans la mesure où ce sont, où encore dans notre société, ce sont les femmes qui sont en charge des enfants, ménage, etc., des affaires intérieures, disons.
Pour elles, la conciliation est d'autant plus difficile. Mais outre cela, il y a un vrai déni de la part des employeurs.
Un déni du fait que y a du sexisme dans la profession, une absence totale de procédures mises en place pour déceler le sexisme, pour lutter contre le sexisme.
Donc, il y a ce déni-là et se confronter à ça tous les jours, plus au sexisme de certains des collègues,
plus au sexisme de certaines sources, hein, extérieures à la rédaction, mais donc des gens qu'on va interviewer, donc le sexisme ambiant.
Pour les femmes, ajouter l'un et l'autre et l'autre, c'est pour certaines vraiment des bonnes raisons de quitter la profession.
Oui, c'est presque paradoxal le fait que ce soit dans les rédactions, ben, de presse, chez les journalistes, qu'on observe finalement une espèce de déni, un décalage par rapport à la réalité.
Le sexisme est très présent, mais d'après ce que tu dis, on fait semblant qu'il n'est pas là.
Donc on sait que ça change pour l'instant. On sent qu'il y a une réelle prise de conscience dans certaines rédactions, mais y a des rédactions qui ont très longtemps été des bastions masculins.
Tu penses à qui, par exemple ?
Particulièrement en presse quotidienne, aux rédactions sportives, clairement. Et ces bastions masculins qui voient l'arrivée de jeunes femmes journalistes, puisqu'elles sont les plus présentes dans les tranches d'âge
entrantes dans la profession,
voient ça un peu comme, bon voilà, quelque chose d'un peu amusant.
Ces gamines qui arrivent, on va les aider. Il y a souvent un paternalisme. Pas toujours bien... et souvent du sexisme bienveillant, si on peut utiliser cette expression que je n'aime pas.
Puisque pour moi, le sexisme n'est jamais bienveillant, mais soit.
Bien intentionné, disons.
Oui, ou quasi inconscient.
Oui, c'est ça, voilà.
Ou en tout cas qui ne souhaite pas être conscient. Et donc il y a vis-à-vis des jeunes femmes journalistes des comportements qui sont tout à fait inacceptables.
Et ça, l'étude le montre vraiment. Mais en plus, nous, ce qu'on sait, parce qu'il y a eu des études comparables qui ont été menées à l'étranger, c'est que c'est pas quelque chose qui est propre à nos rédactions, ici-
D'accord, oui. C'est pas spécifique à la Belgique, oui.
...en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles. Ça existe en Flandre, ça existe également dans d'autres milieux.
Mh.
Donc le sexisme ambiant, il faut le mettre à jour. Quand on est face à un déni des employeurs en disant : « Oh non, pas chez moi, y a aucun problème, non.
» Ou... et quand on est face à un déni des hommes journalistes ou une intégration des stéréotypes, hein, les femmes vont plutôt faire du lifestyle et les hommes, bah, ils iront couvrir les zones de guerre-
Voilà, oui.
...ce type de stéréotypes qui est encore bien vivant, alors c'est beaucoup plus difficile de faire émerger des solutions.
Donc l'idée de la campagne qu'on va lancer cette année-ci et l'année prochaine, c'est justement d'aboutir à des rédactions zéro sexisme, sans harcèlement, parce que le harcèlement, il est évident et moral et sexuel.
On a plein de témoignages qui vont dans ce sens-là.
Donc sans harcèlement, beaucoup plus convivial en termes de conciliation vie privée, vie professionnelle, où la maternité n'est plus un tabou ni un obstacle à la profession, parce que c'est encore le cas.
Et y a aussi toutes les questions de différentiel salarial, parce qu'il y a un vrai différentiel salarial dans la profession.
Donc voilà, on a du travail pour la campagne, c'est pas les thèmes qui manquent.
Bon, la campagne n'est pas encore lancée, mais à ce stade, est-ce que vous sentez un milieu plutôt réceptif ou plutôt réfractaire à cette campagne, à ces changements ?
Alors, je dirais, ça dépend vraiment des rédactions.
Oui.
Parce qu'il y a des rédactions qui ont déjà travaillé sur ces questions-là, comme la rédaction du Soir, par exemple.
Le Soir.
Au Soir, les femmes journalistes ont décidé de se réunir entre elles parce qu'elles avaient des problèmes de ce type-là et de se dire : « Voilà, avec nos collègues masculins » – qui sont quand même
80 % de la rédaction, parce que là, y a vraiment pas beaucoup de femmes au Soir – « avec nos collègues masculins, on va essayer
d'ouvrir la discussion, le débat et d'arriver en fait à deux choses, c'est : comment les hommes et les femmes se comportent entre eux dans la rédaction,
avec quel respect, avec quel code ?
Et puis, comment on traite ces questions-là dans le journal ? Toutes les questions de genre. » Parce que ça, c'est la ligne rédactionnelle.
Et ça, si le public a un peu observé le journal Le Soir, moi, j'ai vu vraiment une différence de ligne rédactionnelle sur les questions de genre, de sexisme.
D'abord, une attention beaucoup plus grande à ces questions-là. Et ensuite, pas mal de jeunes journalistes femmes qui traitent ces questions-là et qui les traitent de façon plus féministe qu'avant, où on observait une-
Mh.
...gentille neutralité.
Donc si tu compares, par exemple, avec, au hasard, La Libre Belgique, tu sens vraiment une différence de,
peut-être un héritage un peu plus patriarcal chez La Libre et un mouvement plus féministe chez Le Soir, si je comprends bien.
Oui, mais les choses sont en train de changer à La Libre Belgique aussi.
Ouais.
Donc à l'intérieur, il y a en tout cas des tentatives d'interrogation sur la ligne rédactionnelle, sur la présence des hommes et des femmes dans les pages, mais aussi sur ce qui se passe dans la rédaction.
Bon voilà, mais c'est pas aussi abouti qu'au Soir.
C'est ça.
Et alors, l'autre rédaction qui a bien travaillé ces questions-là, c'est la RTBF-
Mh.
...qui est la seule rédaction à avoir... le seul média à avoir une cellule égalité-diversité en interne.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait, cette cellule ?
Et donc, en fait, c'est la cellule qui est menée par Safia Kessas-
D'accord.
...et qui travaille à la fois sur les contenus, les contenus en fiction, en info, etc.
Et sur la présence d'origines diverses, de diversité et de genre dans les contenus,
mais aussi sur la manière dont on va intégrer les questions féministes et les questions liées au genre, à la fois dans le traitement de l'information, mais aussi dans les relations entre les hommes et les femmes.
On sent qu'il y a un mouvement peut-être plus abouti dans certaines rédactions, peut-être un peu moins dans d'autres, mais de manière générale, un mouvement et... est-ce que tu es optimiste pour le futur ?
Est-ce que tu penses que, je sais pas, d'ici 10 ans, tu penses que ce sera derrière nous ou bien est-ce que tu penses que ça va être plus long encore ?
Moi, je pense que toutes ces questions qui sont liées au genre, il faut voir un temps long.
Mh, c'est générationnel hein.
Moi, je suis féministe depuis que je suis née. J'ai vu beaucoup de choses changer. Enfin, il faut quand même se souvenir qu'en Belgique, les femmes étaient mineures jusque 1976 hein.
Et que donc, bah, 1976, c'est pas si loin. Moi, j'étais née à l'époque. Et pour avoir une profession-
Je me sens un petit peu vissé.
Pour avoir une profession, les femmes devaient avoir l'accord de leur mari.
Ouais, tout à fait, ouais.
1976, c'est y a 40 ans quoi.
Mh.
Donc,
donc je pense que les questions de genre et d'égalité doivent se voir sur un temps long. On peut remonter encore beaucoup plus loin hein, dans
le... toutes les avancées féministes, les questions qui sont liées à l'avortement.
Et là, maintenant, je pense qu'on sera beaucoup plus peut-être dans des questions plus précises. La question de l'évolution de la langue, qui pour moi est vraiment importante.
Mais je pense que la tendance est plutôt positive pour l'instant, parce que moi, avec mon regard de
féministe sur les 30 dernières années,
bah, y a eu tout un temps où les féministes étaient très seules, où les questions d'égalité de genre n'étaient pas des questions importantes, n'étaient pas des questions--
oui, bien sûr, on en parlait pour faire plaisir aux femmes, mais voilà.
Tandis que là, maintenant, elles sont quand même à chaque fois, je dirais, un élément des débats qu'on mène. Et pour ça, je pense qu'en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, y a quand même-
Une direction de l'égalité des chances qui a fait un énorme boulot de ce côté-là.
Par exemple, quand on fait un budget public, on doit voir quelles sont les incidences sur les hommes et les femmes pour les politiques publiques.
Mh, mh, mh.
Est-ce que les budgets sont genrés ou pas ? C'est super important.
Ces dix dernières années, avec les réseaux sociaux, et cetera, on a effectivement vu un féminisme beaucoup plus félicité, beaucoup plus assumé, beaucoup plus, oui, mis en avant, je dirais.
Moi, je dirais une prise de conscience des hommes. C'est--
Je pense que la grande difficulté des mouvements féministes, ou simplement des mouvements féminins pour l'égalité, pour ceux qui n'aiment pas le mot féministe,
la grande difficulté a toujours été de percoler, de se faire comprendre, de faire en sorte que leurs priorités deviennent les priorités aussi du reste de la société.
Et moi, j'ai toujours entendu chez les hommes, même les hommes bienveillants ou à l'écoute par rapport à ça,
je veux dire, une relative, oui, pas indifférence, mais toujours l'impression que : « Oui OK, ça existe, mais c'est pas si grave que ça.
» Le « c'est pas si grave que ça
» fait en sorte que ça ne devient jamais une priorité. Or, aujourd'hui, j'ai l'impression qu'on a quand même réussi,
tous ces mouvements féministes, les uns à côté des autres, les uns avec les autres, ont quand même réussi à faire monter
les questions de l'égalité déclinées dans tous les domaines, que ce soit les domaines de la vie privée, les questions de violence, les questions d'égalité salariale, toutes ces questions-là qui font partie d'un tout.
J'ai l'impression quand même qu'elles sont maintenant à l'ordre du jour, ce qui n'était pas le cas avant.
Mais donc, tu évoquais il y a un instant la question du,
voilà, de toutes ces femmes qui, autour de 30, 35 ans, 40 ans, sortent de plus en plus, voilà, d'une certaine exode des femmes, une certaine précarité de l'emploi aussi, dont on parle souvent quand on parle du journalisme.
Alors du coup, la question que j'ai envie de poser, c'est : toi qui connais bien ce milieu, le milieu du journalisme et le journalisme
en tant que fonction professionnelle, est-ce que tu conseillerais aujourd'hui à un jeune de devenir journaliste ou bien est-ce que c'est toujours un métier
précaire où on risque de
ben de galérer pour gagner sa vie ?
C'est une donnée constante de la profession. Je veux dire aujourd'hui comme il y a 20 ans. Ça, ça n'a pas changé.
On n'a pas toujours eu des chiffres à ce sujet-là, mais depuis 20, 25 ans, on les a, on les collationne et, bon, on sait quel est le salaire moyen net d'un salarié, le salaire moyen net d'un indépendant.
On voit qu'avant, pour les journalistes indépendants, bah, il y avait un, je dirais, un sas d'entrée dans le statut d'indépendant, un sas d'entrée dans la profession qui durait deux ans, cinq ans.
Maintenant, certains sont là depuis dix ans. Mais ce que l'on voit aussi, c'est qu'il y a des journalistes qui quittent des statuts de salariés pour prendre le statut d'indépendant,
qui veulent plus avoir toutes ces contraintes liées à un employeur.
Donc, on sent aussi que la profession, elle est en train de changer de l'intérieur avec un autre regard sur... et que le CDI est peut-être pas nécessairement le rêve des journalistes.
Je crois que les journalistes aimeraient bien avoir des conditions d'exercice du métier qui permettent que ça reste une profession qui a du sens et pas une profession où on fait de l'abattage.
Parce que certains disent : « Bah moi, je fais de l'abattage. Je dois livrer trois, quatre papiers par jour. J'ai même plus le temps de réfléchir à ce que je fais, aux angles que je prends.
Voilà, si j'ai fait du clic, c'est bien. » Donc, je pense que les journalistes ne veulent plus ça. Ils veulent retrouver du sens à la profession, retrouver du temps pour,
pour faire le métier qu'ils ont envie de faire et en même temps, que cela leur permette d'en vivre, ce qui fait beaucoup de choses à concilier.
Donc est-ce que je conseillerais à un jeune de se lancer ? Oui, en ayant à son arc quelques cordes. Parce que je pense qu'il y a...
Bon, on sait qu'il y a à peu près dix diplômés pour un emploi.
Ah oui, c'est violent, ça.
Et donc ça veut dire qu'il y en a neuf qui vont devoir s'insérer autrement dans la profession ou pas s'insérer du tout.
Donc il y en a sûrement la moitié qui vont pas s'insérer, les autres qui vont essayer de s'insérer dans des statuts un peu hybrides, ce qu'on appelle pigiste salarié, parce qu'on est un peu de tout.
Donc on a des faux indépendants dans la profession, on a des faux salariés aussi.
Et pour certains, au terme de deux, trois ans de difficulté à nouer les deux bouts avec leur profession, bah ils vont sortir, ils vont se réorienter et d'autres vont rester.
Et pour certains, ça va aller très très vite aussi. Après deux ans, ils vont être dans une rédaction, ils vont s'y trouver bien et ils vont faire leur bout de chemin.
Ce qu'on voit aussi beaucoup plus, c'est d'autres organisations du travail. Donc on voit pas mal de journalistes qui créent des collectifs,
donc qui se mettent ensemble dans des locaux, soit en coworking, soit autrement, et qui ont la volonté aussi de rompre l'isolement.
Parce que le problème des journalistes indépendants, c'est souvent qu'ils sont seuls. Ils sont seuls, ils sont pas en lien vraiment avec une rédaction, ils n'ont pas de retour sur leur travail.
Donc, sauf pour ceux qui adorent être solitaires, c'est difficile. La solitude des pigistes, c'est quelque chose qui revient très régulièrement et contre laquelle, je pense, il faut, 'fin, inventer des nouveaux projets.
Vraiment. Et pas mal de journalistes indépendants sont en train d'inventer ces projets. Et je trouve que l'Union professionnelle doit faire quelque chose, là.
Je pense que si nous, on avait un chouette espace à mettre
à disposition des journalistes indépendants à Bruxelles, à Liège, à Namur, à Charleroi, voilà, on pourrait faire du coworking, en plus d'autres choses, en plus que de la création journalistique.
Pas seulement mettre ensemble les gens, mais faire en sorte qu'ils travaillent ensemble. Je trouve qu'il y a des choses à travailler.
C'est quelque chose qui est prévu ou c'est quelque chose de fantasmé que vous-
Ah non, mais tous les projets commencent par des fantasmes hein, donc il faut d'abord se dire-
Est-ce que ce sera toujours fantasmé ou bien est-ce que ce sera réalisé, ces prochaines années par l'AJP ?
Je sais pas parce que ça, on commence seulement à en parler donc-
D'accord. Qu'est-ce qu'il faut pour avoir sa place auprès de l'AJP ? Est-ce qu'il faut obligatoirement avoir la carte de presse ?
Est-ce qu'il faut obligatoirement avoir vendu des piges à une rédaction bien connue en Belgique ? Qu'est-ce que-
Ah oui. Ah ben nous, on travaille dans un cadre légal. Donc en Belgique, y a une loi qui prévoit qui est journaliste professionnel.
D'accord.
Et cette loi dit : « À partir du moment où votre activité principale, c'est le journalisme et que cette activité principale, elle est rémunérée,
alors vous pouvez prétendre à devenir journaliste professionnel », qui est un titre protégé comme médecin ou comme, enfin voilà.
Et ce titre qui est protégé, il est accordé par une commission d'agrégation qui est pas l'AJP, qui est une commission indépendante de l'AJP.
Il y a une commission d'appel et puis après, y a le Conseil d'État. Donc c'est vraiment une commission administrative avec des voies de recours, etc.
Donc c'est organisé, qui a sa jurisprudence. Et cette commission, en fait, tous les mois, elle admet des nouveaux journalistes au titre de journaliste professionnel.
Elle retire aussi des cartes, parce que, pour avoir accès au titre de journaliste professionnel, on peut non plus avoir aucune activité commerciale ou publicitaire.
C'est ça. J'allais en parler, mais donc c'est la même chose que la carte de presse. On parle de—
Oui, c'est ça. Alors une fois qu'on a le titre de journaliste professionnel—
Oui
...est lié au titre une carte de presse officielle. Et cette carte de presse, elle est délivrée par le SPF Intérieur.
Mh.
Donc c'est vraiment une carte de presse officielle. Ça ressemble à une carte d'identité, en fait. Et une fois que les journalistes ont le titre de journaliste professionnel et la carte de presse, ils peuvent devenir membres de l'AJP.
OK. Donc il faut les deux, ouais.
Ouais.
Et—
Mais pour ça, il faut être journaliste depuis deux ans. Pour pouvoir demander le titre, il faut prouver son activité depuis deux ans.
Donc pendant deux ans, ça veut dire que tous les jeunes journalistes sont en dehors de toutes les structures. Donc nous, on a inventé, entre guillemets, on a créé,
ce qu'on appelle le statut de journaliste stagiaire, stagiaire étant le stage de deux ans avant d'arriver au titre journaliste professionnel.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Et les stagiaires peuvent être membres chez nous dès qu'ils peuvent prouver trois mois.
OK. Et donc, pour revenir à la question de la stabilité, la précarité de l'emploi du journalisme en Belgique, j'ai personnellement l'impression d'avoir souvent croisé des personnes qui
étaient autrefois journalistes et puis ils sont devenus copywriters, qui écrivent pour le blog de BNP Paribas pour parler de l'entrepreneuriat en Belgique ou quoi.
Enfin bref, finalement une espèce de, oui, de reconversion vers le secteur privé, vers le secteur commercial,
parce que sans doute, j'ai pas posé la question, mais sans doute une difficulté à vivre du métier de journaliste.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu vois souvent, toi, cette fuite du journalisme vers le secteur privé où voilà, on devient copywriter pour une banque ou ce genre de choses ?
Oui, on le voit très régulièrement. J'ai pas de chiffres là-dessus, sur la sortie vers le secteur globalement de la communication.
C'est ça.
Mais ce que l'on voit, c'est que, comme les journalistes maîtrisent en principe les compétences d'écriture, de prise de parole, notamment en public, bon, ils sont très souvent,
ils ont les capacités d'être porte-parole d'une organisation, donc dans la communication,
de travailler en effet en copywriting, oui, de travailler dans les métiers de la com', qui ont à ce moment-là plus grand-chose à voir avec les métiers du journalisme.
C'est sûr, ouais.
Ce qu'on voit aussi, c'est qu'ils reviennent parfois en disant : « Moi, c'est pas pour moi, hein ». Ou notamment, c'est les journalistes qui passent en politique, donc qui tout à coup se, on,
sont candidats sur une liste, sont élus, font de la politique pendant quelques années et puis qui reviennent en disant : « OK, j'ai vu, ça, c'est pas pour moi.
Moi, j'étais journaliste, je suis resté journaliste dans l'âme ». Et y en a qui reviennent à la profession aussi.
Ouais, ouais. Et donc, on disait, il est indispensable, il est, enfin il est nécessaire pour avoir la carte de presse, pour avoir le statut de journaliste professionnel, d'avoir,
de ne pas avoir d'activité commerciale sur le côté et d'être dédié, voilà, à la fonction journalistique.
Du coup, la question que j'ai envie de te poser, c'est : comment est-ce que toi, tu définis la déontologie journalistique ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est être un bon journaliste, et qu'est-ce que c'est être un mauvais journaliste ?
Ah oui, et donc ça a rien à voir avec la carte de presse parce que quand on délivre, la commission d'agréation délivre la carte de presse, elle regarde pas si les gens sont bons ou mauvais.
Y a pas de critère journalistique. Pardon, y a pas de critère déontologique—
C'est ça
...pour donner la carte de presse, sauf l'interdiction d'activité commerciale et publicitaire, qui est aussi une notion déontologique.
Mais c'est le seul lien entre déontologie et carte de presse.
Par contre, sur les questions de la déontologie, là, on a vraiment bien travaillé ces dix dernières années et même vingt dernières années, pour la profession en Belgique.
Donc, d'une part, il y a eu la création du Conseil de déontologie journalistique, c'était il y a dix ans. Donc, on a quand même maintenant un certain recul sur l'activité déontologique.
Et qu'est-ce qu'il fait exactement ce conseil ? Est-ce qu'il a des— est-ce qu'il juge les mauvais élèves ?
Est-ce qu'il sanctionne quand il y a un problème ?
Alors pardon. D'abord, le conseil, il répond aux demandes du public.
D'accord.
Donc, qu'il s'agisse de plaintes, de demandes d'information, de demandes d'avis, le Conseil de déontologie fournit une réponse sur la déontologie journalistique.
Ensuite, il y a une procédure de plainte. Donc si vous, comme usager des médias, vous avez un souci de type déontologique avec un média qui vous concerne vous-même ou qui concerne
le monde entier, peu importe, il faut pas un intérêt particulier pour agir, vous pouvez introduire une plainte devant le Conseil de déontologie.
Et le Conseil de déontologie, il va prendre la plainte. Donc il va, d'abord, il va regarder si c'est bien une question de déontologie journalistique.
Ensuite, il va traiter le dossier et puis rendre un avis. Et cet avis, il va être transmis aux parties et il va être publié.
Et c'est un avis qui va dire : « Non, y a pas de problème de déontologie » ou « Oui, y a partiellement un problème de déontologie » ou « Oui, y a complètement un problème de déontologie ».
Et ça, ça va être envoyé aux parties, ça va être publié sur le site du Conseil de déontologie et ça va être publié par l'AJP également sur son site.
Voilà, ça, c'est la seule sanction.
C'est ça, oui, OK. Et ensuite, est-ce qu'éventuellement le—
Et pardon, il va être publié aussi par le média concerné.
C'est— Ah ! OK.
En fait, le média concerné, sur son site internet, va devoir faire un lien entre, 'fin un lien, un hyperlien, si vous voulez—
C'est ça, oui, oui
...entre le reportage, l'article qui donne lieu à l'avis et l'avis, et indiquer un résumé de l'avis avec le lien vers l'avis complet.
Autrement dit, le public pourra savoir quand il ouvre cet article qu'il y avait un souci de déontologie par rapport à cet article, ce reportage, et cetera, et pourra voir quel était l'avis du Conseil de déontologie.
Et tu dis le média doit faire ce lien, cet hyperlien.
Oui.
C'est un simple accord ou bien est-ce que c'est législatif ou bien est-ce que— Comment ça se passe ?
Alors, c'est de l'autorégulation.
C'est ça.
Mais c'est de l'autorégulation, je dirais, un peu forcée. C'est un peu un modèle hybride.
OK.
Donc en fait, ce qu'on a voulu, c'est que à la fois les médias s'engagent à respecter la déontologie, mais qu'ils soient quand même un peu obligés de le faire.
Donc dans le décret sur la RTBF, dans le décret sur les aides à la presse quotidienne,
dans ce qui concerne les, les décrets qui concernent les radios privées, et cetera, il existe chaque fois une obligation pour tous ces médias d'être membre du Conseil de déontologie et d'appliquer ses décisions.
Donc, on a—
Mais c'est intéressant puisque c'est—
On a un petit levier légal.
Oui.
Et on a surtout un important levier en autorégulation parce que OK, ils ont été obligés, certains ont plus traîné les pieds que d'autres.
D'autres pas, étaient vraiment preneurs de la création du Conseil de déontologie. Et puis tous ces gens sont ensemble autour de la table.
Donc le Conseil de déontologie, c'est les représentants des médias, un tiers, les représentants des journalistes, un tiers, les représentants de la société civile, le troisième tiers.
Et tout ça, ça fait 40 personnes.
Oui. Et donc vous, vous êtes vraiment un acteur, mais indépendant, extérieur au, voilà, à la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, à l'État, à l'État belge.
Et pourtant, vous revenez quand même, d'après ce que tu disais, dans les textes légaux, il y a une obligation de travailler avec le Conseil de déontologie.
Donc c'est assez—
C'est créatif.
Oui, c'est ça.
Je veux dire, c'est pas un modèle pur. Parce qu'en fait, des conseils déontologie ou des conseils de presse, en Europe, y en a une trentaine, donc y a au moins 30 modèles.
Par exemple, en France, y en a pas, ils arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord. Ça fait 20 ans qu'ils sont en train d'en discuter et ça a pas l'air d'en prendre le chemin, mais y en a dans les pays de l'Est.
'Fin, je dirais, y en a certainement dans les pays nordiques. Donc on— Y en a au Québec aussi, y en a si on sort un peu d'Europe, voilà.
Et donc tous les modèles sont différents. Et par exemple, le modèle de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, il est— c'est pas le même que le modèle flamand, pas tout à fait.
C'est pas très lo— c'est pas très éloigné, mais c'est pas le même. Et ici, c'est pas un modèle pur. Donc c'est un modèle basé sur l'autorégulation, mais quand même avec un peu de régulation.
Et toi, tu aimes bien ou bien tu dirais qu'y a des améliorations possibles à ce niveau-là ?
Moi, je pense que c'est un chouette modèle, parce que c'est à la fois les gens sont forcés d'être là. Comme ils sont forcés d'être là, ils y sont, mais en même temps, autant que l'instance fonctionne.
Je veux dire, on n'a pas vu de tentative de blocage, on n'a pas vu de clivage, par exemple, entre les représentants des médias et les représentants des journalistes.
Absolument pas. Donc les clivages ne se font pas comme ça. Donc c'est pas mal. 'Fin,
j'aurais du mal à dire autre chose parce que j'ai quand même été un peu à l'origine de la création, avec d'autres hein, de la création du Conseil de déontologie,
et donc de l'imagination de ce modèle qui est pas un modèle pur en droit, mais très souvent, les modèles purs ne fonctionnent pas.
Ça, c'est, je reprends ma casquette de juriste. Et je pense que pour qu'un modèle fonctionne, certainement quand il est nouveau,
il faut entendre toutes les demandes qui viennent du secteur, il faut anticiper les difficultés, mais à un certain moment, il faut lancer le truc.
Et peut-être qu'il est susceptible d'amélioration à la marge. Ça, je pense. Par exemple, pour l'instant, il est beaucoup trop sollicité par le public.
D'accord, OK.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
Vous recevez beaucoup de plaintes ?
Oui, beaucoup trop. Donc là, pour l'instant, on est en train de créer de l'arriéré au Conseil de déontologie. Et il faut presque un an pour que certains aient une réponse, qui est absolument pas normale.
Il faudrait une réponse dans les trois mois. Donc, qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport à ça ? Deux solutions : soit on durcit à l'entrée en disant : « Vous ne portez plainte que si vous avez un intérêt à le faire, personnel.
» Ce que font les Flamands hein.
D'accord.
Donc, ils ont moins de plaintes.
Ici, c'est pas le cas. Soit on renforce les moyens du Conseil de déontologie en disant : « OK, c'est bien que les gens s'intéressent, c'est bien que le public ait des questions et des plaintes sur les questions de déontologie.
Il faut toutes les prendre et il faut y répondre. » Alors, il faut doubler les moyens du Conseil de déontologie. Donc ça, c'est l'option qu'on a prise pour l'instant.
Et justement, ces ressources financières, ça vient... Ça vient du contribuable ou d'où viennent vos ressources en fait ?
Alors, il y a le Conseil déontologie, il est paritairement financé par le secteur, donc les éditeurs—
Oui
...tous les médias, en ce compris RTL d'ailleurs. Tous les médias mettent la moitié des ressources du Conseil déontologie.
Et en principe, l'AJP met l'autre moitié des ressources. Sauf que l'AJP, elle a pas de fonds propres. Donc qu'est-ce que l'AJP a été faire ?
Elle a été chercher un financement public.
C'est ça.
Pour payer la part des journalistes au Conseil déontologie. Donc le—
Et du coup, tu présentais deux options : soit on durcit à l'entrée, soit on renforce les ressources. Quelle est ton option préférée ? Qu'est-ce qui—
Renforcer les ressources.
Oui. Et est-ce que ça plaît aux éditeurs ? Est-ce que ça plaît au service public ?
Oui, donc ça a été discuté avant. Et comme on est en période où les déclarations gouvernementales et les gouvernements sont en train de se mettre en place—
Ouais
...c'est le bon moment, justement. Quand on a des demandes de ce type-là, c'est d'une part de se mettre d'accord dans le secteur.
Et donc nous avons dit : « Si on double les moyens du Conseil déontologie, ben oui, la part des éditeurs, elle doit doubler aussi ».
Donc chaque éditeur devra mettre un peu plus, en clair. Y a un accord des éditeurs là-dessus. Maintenant, il faut obtenir l'accord de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles sur le fait qu'il faut doubler la subvention au Conseil déontologie.
Donc ça, c'est un peu notre boulot et on l'a fait dans le cadre de l'audition de la société civile lors des Rencontres Coquelicots.
Maintenant, il faut voir ce que ça va devenir puisqu'ils sont toujours en train de discuter en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles pour la suite.
Voilà, mais c'est un dossier qu'on va suivre. Moi, j'ai l'impression qu'il pourrait bien aboutir.
OK, donc t'es optimiste à ce niveau-là ?
De toute façon, il faut être optimiste hein, parce que sinon on fait rien.
Du coup, je reviens à la question d'origine : comment est-ce que tu définis la déontologie journalistique ? Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Ah oui, oui, c'est vrai, il y avait cette question-là.
Oui, oui, mais c'est bien, on a posé le contexte, c'est tout ça. Mais maintenant...
Et donc, la déontologie, c'est l'ensemble des pratiques d'une profession. Et c'est l'ensemble des règles que la profession s'est donnée par rapport à ses pratiques professionnelles.
Y a un code de déontologie qui existe. Y a toujours eu un code de déontologie dans la profession. 'Fin, on va pas remonter à Mathusalem, mais...
Et en 2013, le Conseil de déontologie a décidé de réécrire le code, donc de le remettre à jour, de le repenser, de le préciser.
Et donc ce code, il est en ligne sur l'ecdj.be, pour ceux que ça intéresse. Et puis, il y a des recommandations sur des thèmes particuliers.
Par exemple, la couverture journalistique en période d'élection. Parce qu'en période d'élection, y a quand même des règles spécifiques à suivre sur l'équilibre, sur toute une série de choses.
Y a une autre recommandation sur comment parler des migrants, de la migration. Y a une autre recommandation sur les questions plus économiques, financières, délits d'initiés, etc.
Tout ça, les journalistes économiques sont aussi confrontés à des questions de déontologie. Y a une recommandation sur quels sont les rapports des journalistes avec leurs sources.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Qu'est-ce qu'on ne fait pas ? Est-ce qu'on peut payer une source ? Oui, non ? Discussion déontologique.
Et pour finir, code. Donc, je dirais, on a maintenant un corpus de règles qui est assez évolué, qui est, mais qui est évolutif aussi.
Donc, on— régulièrement, le Conseil de déontologie va remettre sur le métier certaines règles. Et puis, y a des nouvelles choses qui arrivent.
Par exemple, l'AJP, et non pas le Conseil déontologie, a travaillé sur la manière dont les journalistes parlent des violences contre les femmes dans les journaux, dans...
'Fin voilà, en faisant toute une série de suggestions. Bon, ça fait pas encore partie des codes de déontologie, mais pour moi, c'est le premier pas.
C'est que l'union professionnelle fasse d'abord des recommandations à ses membres et puis ensuite, peut-être que dans cinq ans, ça va se retrouver dans les codes déontologie.
Parfait, on aura fait notre boulot.
Mais donc qui sont des recommandations qui sont finalement l'implémentation, l'application—
C'est ça
...de ces règles générales sur ces—
Ouais
...des sujets précis. Et du coup, une question dont j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter avec, voilà, des journalistes français, en l'occurrence.
Est-ce que journaliste, c'est obligatoirement un métier ? Est-ce que c'est une fonction ? Par exemple, voilà.
Est-ce que moi, quand je vais rencontrer Alexander De Croo pour l'interviewer, quand je vais rencontrer Thierry Geerts de Google pour l'interviewer, est-ce que—
c'est pas mon activité principale, je ne gagne pas d'argent en faisant ça, mais je fais finalement des interviews, j'informe mes auditeurs.
Est-ce que du coup je suis journaliste, même si je ne gagne pas ma vie en tant que journaliste ? Comment ça se passe à ce niveau-là ?
Oui, tu seras pas journaliste professionnel au sens de la loi dont on parlait tout à l'heure—
C'est ça.
...puisque tu gagnes pas ta vie,
Ouais.
...voilà. Mais tu utilises des techniques que les journalistes utilisent. Et ce qui est important aussi, c'est de s'interroger sur l'intention.
Quelle est ton intention en faisant ça ? Est-ce que tu as l'intention d'informer le public ?
Mh.
Auquel cas... 'fin, parce que ça, pour moi, c'est vraiment central.
Oui.
Les journalistes disposent de la liberté d'informer, mais pas pour eux tout seuls. Ils en disposent pour informer le public.
Donc, y a vraiment toujours une question d'intention à l'acte journalistique. Et puis la question de la déontologie, elle est liée.
Parce que si tu penses faire du travail journalistique, tu dois appliquer les règles journalistiques, les règles de la déontologie. Parce que—
Que je ne connais pas.
Non, 'fin, je veux dire, je pense que ça, c'est vraiment intéressant.
Oui.
Avant, les moyens de communication étaient réservés aux médias—
Forcément.
...et donc étaient réservés aux journalistes—
Aujourd'hui, c'est décentralisé.
...pour des semaines. Voilà. Aujourd'hui, tout le monde a accès aux moyens de communication. Et tout le monde s'imagine que puisqu'il a accès aux moyens de communication, il est aussi journaliste.
Ouais. OK. Donc c'est effectivement la question de la déontologie.
Moi, je soigne mon chat, mais je suis pas vétérinaire hein.
C'est ça.
Mais tout le monde peut soigner son chat.
Mh.
Mais je suis pas vétérinaire. Là, on fait bien la différence.
Autrement dit, je—
Le journalisme, c'est un métier. Donc c'est pas seulement une occupation, c'est pas un passe-temps, c'est pas seulement parler dans un micro ou écrire sur un blog ou dans une revue.
Journalisme, c'est un métier.
Donc ta réponse est plutôt : « Non, je ne suis pas journaliste », puisque ce n'est pas mon métier.
Donc ma réponse, elle est plus nuancée que ça. Pour ce qui nous concerne, comme c'est un métier, on considère qu'il faut pouvoir en vivre.
Ouais.
C'est pas un mandat bénévole—
Pour le statut journaliste professionnel, oui.
C'est pas un hobby. Ouais, vous pouvez être journaliste comme hobby, pourquoi pas ?
Oui, donc c'est possible.
Mais pour nous, ça reste un métier. Mais bon, nous, on est l'union professionnelle.
Oui, voilà, c'est forcément, vous avez—
L'angle, c'est l'angle de l'union professionnelle. Et au plus il y a des gens qui vont exercer ce métier de façon bénévole, au moins il y aura de professionnels, clairement.
Mais donc autrement dit, je dois un petit peu aller surfer sur le site du Conseil de déontologie pour regarder un petit peu si mes méthodes sont compatibles.
Et si c'est le cas, alors je peux revendiquer le statut de journaliste hobbyiste, si j'ai bien compris.
Et du coup, puisqu'on parle de... on revient un petit peu sur l'AJP,
voilà, tu m'as refilé une petite brochure ici où il est indiqué que, selon les années, l'AJP rassemble entre 76 et 86 % des journalistes professionnels et stagiaires.
Donc c'est pas l'intégralité. Du coup—
Ah non, mais attends, c'est un taux d'affiliation extraordinaire.
Oui, oui, certainement.
Si on prend le taux d'affiliation des journalistes aux syndicats traditionnels, on est à moins de 20 %.
D'accord, OK. Je ne voulais pas dire que c'était faible. Simplement—
Ah non, non, mais donc il y a des gens qui sont pas membres, ça, clairement.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Il y en a qui—
Et du coup, j'ai envie de poser la question
: est-ce que l'AJP a des ennemis ? Est-ce que tous les journalistes belges francophones vous aiment ou bien est-ce que certains n'apprécient pas votre travail ?
Oh, il y en a certainement qui ne nous aiment pas, mais ceux-là, on les entend pas beaucoup puisqu'ils sont pas membres, évidemment.
Donc ils viennent pas aux assemblées, ils viennent pas aux activités qu'on organise, ils ont pas recours à nos services, donc ils nous téléphonent pas.
Donc voilà. Je pense qu'il y a des personnes qui ne sont pas membres pour des raisons économiques.
Donc chez nous, pour être membre, il faut payer une cotisation.
D'accord, OK.
La cotisation annuelle pour un professionnel, c'est 145 euros. Il y a des journalistes— c'est pas beaucoup.
Ouais, c'est pas beaucoup, effectivement.
Aux Pays-Bas, c'est vingt fois plus. Vingt fois. Bon, il y a plus de services aussi hein, parce qu'ils ont pas mal de rentrées financières.
La cotisation à un syndicat, c'est plus cher que ça aussi. Ça reste modéré comme contribution, mais certains jeunes nous disent : « Je suis désolé, mais ça, c'est trop pour moi.
Cette année-ci, je suis pas membre. » Bon, je pense que ça, c'est une minorité. L'autre, c'est plus idéologique, en effet, c'est : « Moi, je ne veux être membre de rien. »
Oui.
OK. Ça, c'est le droit des gens. Parce que la liberté d'association, c'est la liberté de s'associer, mais c'est aussi celle de ne pas s'associer.
Donc nous, on respecte ça tout à fait. Et puis il y a des gens qui sont, et ça, il y en a beaucoup chez les journalistes, qui sont négligents.
C'est : « Oui, je suis pas membre parce que j'ai oublié de payer ma cotisation. » Et ça, il y en a beaucoup plus qu'on ne pense.
Et puis il y a certainement des gens qui ne nous aiment pas. Mais voilà, je pense que si on faisait la complète unanimité, on devrait se poser des questions aussi hein.
Et du coup, donc, j'aimerais revenir un instant sur une actualité peut-être un peu plus récente.
Parce que donc un exemple du rôle que peut jouer l'AJP, c'est ce qui s'est passé dernièrement avec les éditions du groupe L'Avenir.
On a pu lire en février que la direction des éditions de L'Avenir a refusé la demande de l'AJP d'appliquer la Convention de travail des journalistes.
J'ai l'impression que c'est un dossier que les journalistes ont tous suivi de près et que c'est très clair pour eux, mais de l'extérieur, c'est peut-être un peu moins clair.
On comprend pas tout. Est-ce que tu peux juste nous rappeler un petit peu ce qui se passe avec le groupe L'Avenir et le rôle que l'AJP joue là-dedans ?
Donc depuis maintenant quatre ans, le groupe L'Avenir est possédé par Netys.
Ouais.
Qui est donc une intercommunale publique. Donc il a un actionnaire public, ce qui est le cas la première fois pour un journal dans une—
Presse écrite, ouais.
Ouais, de presse écrite en Europe, je crois qu'il y a pas d'équivalent. Soit, ça peut quand même fonctionner.
C'est un journal régional qui est vraiment ancré dans les communes, dans les villes, voilà. Et on se dit : « Pourquoi pas ?
» Moi, je n'ai pas de souci par rapport à ça. Par contre, d'autres en avaient un, en disant : « Il n'appartient pas aux pouvoirs publics de détenir— »
La question se pose en tout cas, ça, c'est certain.
La question se pose, c'est une question à débattre. Mais ce n'est pas tellement ça, c'est que pendant quatre ans, ce groupe n'a pas investi dans le journal,
alors qu'on sait que tous les journaux investissent dans le numérique, vont chercher leurs lecteurs, gardent leurs lecteurs.
C'est très très difficile pour l'instant de faire fonctionner un journal. Et c'est un groupe qui, pendant quatre ans, n'a rien fait.
Ils le reconnaissent hein, donc on peut le dire sans souci. Et puis tout à coup, ils ont quand même décidé que, bah voilà, alors il fallait faire un plan de restructuration.
Ça, c'est la première grosse décision qu'ils ont prise.
Ouais.
Bah évidemment, parce qu'un journal dans lequel on n'investit pas, c'est un journal qui périclite. Et donc, en raison de leur incurie en gestion, parce que quand ils ont racheté L'Avenir, L'Avenir était un journal qui faisait du bénéfice.
Et puis évidemment, il a périclité. Et donc ils ont fait un plan de restructuration annoncé en octobre 2018, négocié par les syndicats, pas par l'AJP, puisqu'on ne peut pas travailler comme un syndicat hein.
Donc, on a laissé les syndicats travailler. Plan de restructuration qui, sur les conditions de départ, est pas mauvais en soi,
mais on se rend compte que, au fur et à mesure que les 65 personnes qui doivent quitter l'entreprise reçoivent leur décompte, que les conventions qui sont d'application pour les journalistes sont pas respectées.
Donc les conventions qui sont d'application pour les journalistes, c'est des conventions qui prévoient que les journalistes sont payés d'une part en salaire, d'autre part en droits d'auteur.
Et que quand ils quittent l'entreprise, on doit leur payer une indemnité de préavis, mais aussi une indemnité en droits d'auteur.
Et que les calculs sont faits de telle et telle manière. Donc tout ça est prévu par les conventions, tout ça est très clair.
Sauf que les syndicats qui ont négocié ça, bah ils ont lu la convention, ils ont peut-être pas tout compris, tout capté, je sais pas, on sait pas où est l'erreur.
Mais en tout cas, ils ont dit : « OK, ça va, c'est bon comme ça, on va faire de telle manière. » Sauf que le
« de telle manière » faisait en sorte que les journalistes perdaient des milliers, voire des dizaines de milliers d'euros pour certains.
Donc on a mené le combat en interne en disant : « Vous devez respecter les conventions qui sont applicables aux journalistes et le fait qu'il y a un plan de restructuration ne vous exonère pas de ce respect-là.
» On a dû batailler pendant des semaines pour obtenir ça. On a fini par l'obtenir.
Super.
Donc voilà. Mais ça, c'est pas le seul problème qui se pose. D'abord, batailler pour obtenir le respect des conventions, ça, je trouve que c'est déjà un souci.
Le problème qui se pose, c'est la gestion du journal et le respect de l'indépendance des rédactions. Ça, c'est un vrai problème.
Y a plus de rédacteur en chef à L'Avenir, il est parti. Il a été remplacé, entre guillemets, je mets quatre guillemets, par un directeur des rédactions.
Mh.
Et en fait, ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est que dans un média de presse quotidienne, quand on désigne un rédacteur en chef, on doit consulter la rédaction.
Mais ici, comme on n'a pas désigné un rédacteur en chef, mais un directeur de rédaction, la rédaction, elle a pas été consultée.
Donc cette personne arrive et commence à se comporter comme un rédacteur en chef et donc la rédaction a dit tout de suite : « Non.
Non, vous n'êtes pas rédacteur en chef, vous êtes directeur. » C'est pas la même chose.
Mh.
Le rédacteur en chef, c'est celui qui va préserver l'indépendance de la rédaction vis-à-vis de l'actionnaire, et ici, c'est vraiment important, comme vis-à-vis de toute pression, qu'elle soit de type interne ou externe.
Donc le fait qu'il y ait pas de rédacteur en chef, c'est un problème. Le fait que le directeur des rédactions agisse comme un rédacteur en chef, c'est un autre problème.
Et puis il y a eu des licenciements ciblés. Il y a eu des licenciements de journalistes qui ont été, selon nous, opérés par la direction, en guise de représailles.
Parce qu'en fait, cette rédaction de L'Avenir, elle a résisté de façon extraordinaire. Donc, d'une part, elle a embarqué les lecteurs de son côté dans la lutte en organisant des solidarités avec les lecteurs.
D'autre part, elle a travaillé sur l'humour et surtout,
ce qui est exceptionnel, et ça, j'espère que les historiens le diront un jour, mais ce qui est exceptionnel, c'est que la rédaction de L'Avenir a utilisé son propre journal pour informer sur son propre conflit.
Et ça, c'est très rare.
Mh. Ouais.
Si vous avez un conflit à la RTBF, si vous voulez comprendre ce qui se passe à la RTBF, n'écoutez pas la RTBF.
C'est ça, ouais, ouais.
Parce que la RTBF va pas faire un débat sur ce qui se passe en interne. Au contraire. Si vous avez une grève au journal Le Soir, lisez plutôt La Libre, si vous voulez comprendre, parce que—
Mh.
Le Soir va pas faire trois pages sur son conflit. Eh ben les journalistes de L'Avenir, ils ont décidé de faire ça, de faire des pages sur leur propre conflit et de façon journalistique.
Les journalistes en interne ont établi un rapport de force en disant : « Le conflit qui est à l'œuvre depuis l'annonce du plan de restructuration et qui se poursuit jusqu'à ce jour intéresse nos lecteurs.
S'il intéresse nos lecteurs, nos lecteurs doivent trouver l'information dans notre journal, sur notre site internet.
» Et ça, c'est une petite révolution parce que jusque-là, les journalistes ont une certaine pudeur à parler des questions qui agitent la profession et d'autant plus lorsqu'elles agitent leur propre média.
Ouais.
Donc cette couverture journalistique, ils l'ont fait de façon journalistique, en donnant la parole à la direction, en donnant la parole aux syndicats, en donnant la parole à l'AJP
et en faisant pour leurs lecteurs un résumé assez clair de ce qui s'était passé.
Je dois dire que moi, en tant que lecteur, j'aurais malgré tout, pour le principe, tendance à privilégier une information extérieure plutôt que d'entendre les journalistes du groupe L'Avenir juger leur situation.
Enfin, pas juger, mais couvrir journalistiquement leur situation. Enfin, j'aurais immédiatement tendance à dire : « Ben non, je préfère lire, je préfère m'informer ailleurs à ce sujet. »
D'accord, mais l'information la plus complète qu'on a lue sur le conflit, c'est dans les pages de L'Avenir.
Ouais, donc c'est presque paradoxal.
Ceci dit, les autres médias ont couvert aussi.
Oui.
Mais ce qui est exceptionnel, c'est que L'Avenir a couvert lui-même—
Ouais, effectivement, c'est...
son propre conflit. Mais il faut savoir que—
C'est notable.
...ce sont des équipes où il y a énormément de professionnalisme,
du talent et de la résilience. Parce que tout ce à quoi ils sont confrontés depuis des mois, je pense que dans d'autres rédactions, la moitié des gens seraient partis.
Et du coup ?
Et du coup, l'AJP, par rapport à ce conflit, OK, on est extérieur à l'entreprise, mais on a 95 % d'affiliés à L'Avenir, vraiment beaucoup dans la rédaction.
Et on est un peu les derniers à résister. Donc sur la question de l'indépendance rédactionnelle, il y a la Société des rédacteurs qui est une société interne qui rassemble tous les journalistes et il y a l'AJP.
Les syndicats ne sont absolument pas présents dans ce conflit depuis des mois maintenant. Et d'ailleurs, je pense que ces questions-là sont pas de leur compétence.
C'est des questions qui touchent à la déontologie, à l'organisation des rédactions, à l'indépendance.
Très spécifique au journalisme, ouais.
Donc on est les derniers à résister. Donc les
derniers épisodes de ce conflit qui est très très dur hein,
c'est l'interdiction par Netis, par la direction des éditions de L'Avenir, interdiction faite à l'AJP de tenir des réunions, de tenir des assemblées générales,
interdiction qui m'est faite personnellement d'entrer dans l'entreprise, des choses qu'on a vues nulle part ailleurs.
D'accord, ouais.
Donc moi, j'ai dit : « Namur n'est pas en Birmanie, pas encore. »
Ouais.
Donc on va, nous, appliquer les conventions qu'on a qui prévoient que oui, on peut réunir le personnel, oui, on peut l'informer, oui, je peux rentrer dans l'entreprise.
Voilà, ce dernier épisode-là, c'est un—
C'est assez choquant.
épisode très très dur et très choquant.
Oui, c'est assez choquant, mais surtout de la part d'une intercommunale publique d'avoir une approche aussi violente par rapport au journalisme.
J'ai l'impression que quand tu dis que, donc une interdiction personnelle d'entrer dans le bâtiment, si j'ai bien compris.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a reçu ici deux ou trois lettres recommandées disant que dorénavant, sauf autorisation de la direction, aucune personne de l'AJP extérieure à la rédaction, moi en l'occurrence,
par exemple, ou mon président ou quelqu'un qui n'est pas des éditions de L'Avenir, qu'aucune de ces personnes ne pourrait rentrer dans l'entreprise. Voilà.
Ouais, ouais. Oui, c'est, c'est—
Pour moi, c'est une entrave à la liberté d'association, une entrave à la liberté d'information des travailleurs.
On nous a reproché aussi d'avoir déposé un préavis de grève, mais quand on n'avait pas déposé de préavis et qu'on avait fait grève, on nous avait reproché de ne pas avoir déposé de préavis de grève.
Donc quoi qu'on fasse, en toute hypothèse, ce qui dérange cet actionnaire, c'est qu'on résiste. Et on est les derniers à résister.
Donc l'enjeu du conflit pour l'instant, en tout cas pour Netis, c'est de nous éliminer du terrain. Après ça, ils auront la voie libre pour faire de ce journal je ne sais pas quoi, parce qu'on n'a jamais su ce que Netis voulait faire avec ce journal.
Oui, c'est un peu toute la question. Parce que effectivement, quand moi, je discute avec mes,
mes copains de La Libre Belgique,
eux, ils sont toujours très fiers d'expliquer que chez eux, tout va bien et que les chiffres, la flèche monte vers le haut et que les chiffres sont dans le vert, que tout baigne, tout tout va super bien.
Et inversement, j'ai l'impression que— enfin, alors, ils se vantent d'avoir très bien réussi ce tournant, ce shift vers le numérique.
Et inversement, d'après ce que tu m'expliques, le groupe L'Avenir ne l'a pas trop fait. Il y a pas eu d'investissement de la part de Netis à ce niveau-là.
Donc j'ai l'impression que,
finalement, ce qui explique d'une part la mauvaise situation de L'Avenir et la bonne situation de La Libre, c'est finalement le fait qu'il y en a un qui a eu l'intelligence d'investir dans le numérique et l'autre pas. Enfin...
Je pense que La Libre et La Dernière Heure, donc le groupe IPM, comme le groupe Rossel avec Sud Presse et Le Soir, tous les jours se battent sur le développement numérique de leur modèle économique.
Donc ils y ont mis des ressources, ils font en sorte que ça fonctionne, ils proposent des choses à leurs lecteurs, ils investissent.
Et à— pied à pied hein, parce qu'il faut non seulement garder les lecteurs actuels, mais aller en chercher d'autres.
Et ça, c'est très très difficile. L'Avenir n'a pas eu cette politique-là simplement parce que la direction n'a rien mis en place qui permettait de faire ça.
Néanmoins, et ce qui sauve peut-être L'Avenir, c'est que contrairement aux autres journaux, ses lecteurs sont abonnés à 90 %.
Ouais.
Donc les journaux, ils se vendent soit en abonnement, soit la vente de numéros en kiosque. Y a des journaux qui se vendent essentiellement en kiosque et d'autres par abonnement.
L'Avenir, ils ont un taux d'abonnement et de réabonnement qui est assez exceptionnel. Donc ça, ça les sauve pour l'instant.
Maintenant, je serais pas aussi optimiste sur la réussite des modèles numériques dans les autres groupes de presse.
D'accord, OK.
Je pense qu'il y a toujours deux discours. Il y a un discours pour l'externe, un discours pour l'interne.
Et moi, j'espère vraiment que ça va fonctionner parce que si ça fonctionne pas, ça veut dire perte de titres, donc de pluralisme, donc d'emplois.
Donc il faut que les modèles fonctionnent. Ça, vraiment. Et là, on a des gros enjeux devant nous qui sont les enjeux par rapport aux GAFA.
Donc des enjeux par rapport à Google, Amazon, Facebook, etc. Les auditeurs ont peut-être entendu ce qui s'est passé au niveau européen.
La réforme du copyright.
La directive droit voisin hein, qu'on appelle comme ça, qui devrait produire en fait pour les éditeurs de contenu, et notamment les éditeurs de journaux, mais aussi ceux qui produisent le contenu, c'est-à-dire les journalistes,
qui devraient in fine produire un retour, des montants qui sont captés par les GAFA.
Les GAFA qui sont en fait en train de manger le contenu, puis ils le revendent à d'autres et ils en gardent les bénéfices.
Donc l'idée, c'est d'avoir un retour de bénéfices en raison de la création de ce droit voisin. Et c'est en fait de rétablir un peu des flux économiques équitables dans le secteur.
En même temps, si les éditeurs ont réussi à obtenir ce droit voisin, c'est parce que les auteurs ont bien voulu collaborer.
Je veux dire, au départ, il y avait pas mal d'auteurs, et notamment en France, donc des sociétés de gestion de droits d'auteurs, des organisations d'auteurs qui disaient : « Mais pourquoi créer un nouveau droit pour les éditeurs ?
C'est nous qui avons les droits d'auteurs, ce sont les auteurs ». Donc il y a eu au départ cette opposition qui, de longue date, entre les auteurs et les éditeurs.
Et à un certain moment, on s'est dit : « En fait, on va pas se battre entre nous. L'ennemi, c'est— l'ennemi, c'est ni l'un ni l'autre.
L'ennemi, il est en face. Arrêtons de nous battre dans nos propres troupes ». Mais ça veut dire que les éditeurs doivent jouer le jeu jusqu'au bout.
Parce que pour obtenir le droit voisin, ils ont dû s'allier avec les auteurs. Maintenant, il ne faudrait pas que s'ils vont chercher les revenus des GAFA, ils oublient qu'ils se sont alliés avec les auteurs.
Donc la directive prévoit quand même qu'il doit y avoir une redistribution équitable vis-à-vis des auteurs. Et là, nous, on sera particulièrement attentifs.
C'est un gros dossier à venir, mais c'est notamment quelque chose qui pourrait améliorer le revenu des journalistes indépendants.
Parce que si les journalistes indépendants sont aussi mal payés, c'est aussi parce que les moyens économiques des médias sont faibles, à la marge en tout cas.
Et donc, si on va chercher avec les éditeurs des flux financiers qui permettent de mieux financer le journalisme, tout à fait normal que les plus précaires de la profession en profitent.
Et c'est là qu'on voit que tous les dossiers sont liés.
Mhm. Oui. Et puisqu'on parle, donc on parle plus sur l'aspect légal à ce stade, j'ai envie de poser une question sur, ben, la protection des journalistes en Belgique, la protection des sources.
Est-ce que les journalistes et le secret des sources sont bien protégés en Belgique ? Est-ce que les lanceurs d'alerte sont bien protégés en Belgique ?
Est-ce qu'on est
Voilà, parce que je sais que dans certains pays du tiers monde, c'est, voilà, tu disais : « On n'est pas en Birmanie », mais est-ce qu'on est tellement mieux que la Birmanie ou est-ce que...
Oui, on est beaucoup mieux. On est dans un pays, et on s'en rend pas toujours compte, où la liberté de la presse existe.
Oui, ça, c'est certain.
Et en général—
Question un peu provoc de ma part hein, mais...
Est respectée.
Ouais.
Mais on doit vraiment le redire et— mais rester vigilant, parce que ça peut très vite dégringoler ce genre de situation.
Mais donc, on est dans un pays de liberté.
Il n'y a pas de situation où un journaliste se fait poursuivre en justice pour avoir révélé—
Ah oui, oui, si, si, il y en a plein.
Ça arrive.
Oui, c'est ça.
Voilà. Mais ça, la question méritait d'être posée : où est-ce qu'on en est à ce stade ?
Bon alors, y a plusieurs choses. Le cadre légal en Belgique ne protège pas les journalistes. Les journalistes ont très peu de protection.
En fait, c'est la liberté d'expression qui est protégée.
C'est ça.
Et les journalistes utilisent évidemment la liberté d'expression. Donc ceux qui utilisent la liberté d'expression sont, entre guillemets, protégés, mais c'est un régime qui fonctionne sur la sanction a posteriori.
D'abord, on s'exprime, ensuite, on est sanctionné. Mais donc c'est un régime qui fonctionne sur la liberté et la responsabilité.
Et ça, c'est les régimes de liberté qui fonctionnent. Il y a toujours une responsabilité qui est liée à la liberté.
Vous avez la liberté de, mais si vous déconnez, si vous diffamez, si vous mentez, si vous trichez, si vous volez, alors vous serez responsable.
Si vous faites bien votre boulot, vous continuez à utiliser la liberté, y a pas de souci. Donc notre régime de liberté de la presse, il a été conçu de cette manière-là.
Ça, c'est une première chose et ça fonctionne assez bien. Y a des actions en responsabilité contre les journalistes, y a des actions au pénal aussi contre les journalistes.
C'est fréquent ? C'est rare ou... ?
Ouais, nous, on a ici, à l'Union professionnelle, qu'est-ce qu'on a ? En matière de responsabilité, on a cinq, six dossiers par an.
D'accord, OK.
Donc
C'est relativement peu, j'ai l'impression.
C'est relativement peu. Y a eu des périodes dans l'histoire de la Belgique où il y en a eu beaucoup plus, notamment toute la couverture de l'affaire Dutroux—
Ouais
a donné lieu à énormément de procès contre les journalistes, voilà, avec des résultats divers au final, des condamnations, mais aussi beaucoup de dossiers où il s'est rien passé.
Donc y a des actions en justice contre les journalistes. L'Union professionnelle, qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ? Elle met à disposition un avocat et elle prend en charge les frais d'avocat.
Voilà, si le journaliste est membre. Donc ça, c'est un service qu'on prend et on travaille avec des bureaux d'avocats spécialisés en droit des médias.
Alors, la question de la protection des sources, c'est une autre question. C'est— qui concerne pas tellement les journalistes, qui concerne les sources.
Oui.
Donc en fait—
Ben, est-ce qu'on peut exiger d'un journaliste qu'il divulgue cette information ? Est-ce qu'on peut le forcer à révéler ça ?
Ça concerne aussi les journalistes.
On a depuis 2005 une législation qui protège le secret des sources journalistiques—
Oui
...qui est une des meilleures législations en Europe.
Nickel.
qui est citée comme telle et qui est vraiment l'exemple pour tous les autres pays qui n'en auraient pas encore.
C'est une très bonne loi. Et qu'est-ce qu'elle prévoit, cette loi ? Qu'en principe, on peut pas demander à un journaliste de révéler ses sources confidentielles.
En principe. Il y a une exception : lorsque la révélation de ces sources permettrait d'éviter une atteinte à l'intégrité physique.
Exemple : tu es journaliste, tu apprends qu'il va y avoir un attentat. Tu informes quand même la police en disant : « Il faut évacuer le quartier là, parce que voilà ».
Mais on peut te forcer à révéler tes sources dans ce cas-là.
Ouais.
Dire qui t'a donné l'information. C'est des situations où en général, on se pose pas trop de questions hein, sur—
C'est déjà arrivé, ça ?
Oui, pas cet exemple-là, mais d'autres exemples où l'intégrité physique est mise en cause et où on a levé les sources.
Je pense que depuis 2005, y en a pas eu.
D'accord, ouais. Bon voilà, donc—
Par contre, ce qu'il y a eu avant 2005, y avait beaucoup de perquisitions dans les rédactions. On arrivait, on prenait votre ordinateur, voilà, on le vidait.
Ouais.
Donc on a dû, nous, comme Union professionnelle, avec des journalistes, assigner la Belgique devant la Cour européenne des droits de l'Homme, ce qu'on a fait, et on a gagné.
Et c'est après cela qu'il y a eu cette législation sur la protection des sources. Donc ça, je dirais que de ce côté-là, on est plutôt tranquille,
mais on doit, à chaque fois qu'il y a des nouvelles législations en Belgique, vérifier qu'on respecte bien cette législation-là.
Donc par exemple, y a eu la transposition de la directive sur le secret des affaires, hein, une grande disposition qui permet aux entreprises de protéger leur secret d'affaires.
Mais qu'est-ce qui se passe quand il y a des révélations de journalistes de secret d'affaires ? Et qu'est-ce qui se passe avec le secret des sources ?
Donc à chaque fois qu'il y a une nouvelle législation, on doit se poser la question.
Ouais. Quand tu parles de secret d'affaires, on parle de lanceurs d'alerte, de personnes qui révèlent des scandales ?
Alors, soit c'est révélé par un lanceur d'alerte, soit c'est révélé par un journaliste dont la source est un lanceur d'alerte et qu'il peut protéger par son secret des sources.
Mais est-ce que justement, cette législation permet de protéger ce lanceur d'alerte ? Donc ce qu'on a vu, par exemple, en Belgique, c'est que dans la transposition de la directive sur les secrets d'affaires,
il est prévu qu'en effet, on ne poursuivra pas quelqu'un qui a révélé des informations dans le but d'utiliser la liberté d'expression. Voilà.
Mais ça n'empêchera pas, par exemple, les procédures-bâillons. Ça veut dire que ça n'empêchera pas une entreprise d'assigner 20 journalistes parce qu'ils ont révélé des soi-disant pseudo secrets d'affaires.
Ces journalistes vont devoir se défendre une fois, deux fois, cinq fois.
C'est ce qu'on appelle des procédures-bâillons. Ça veut dire que ce sont des procédures qui font qu'à terme, les journalistes vont éviter de parler de ce genre de société parce qu'ils savent qu'ils vont être assignés.
D'accord, oui.
Genre, je ne sais pas moi, si—
Ça a moins de pression quoi, une—
Si chaque fois qu'on parle de glyphosate, Monsanto ou Bayer vous assigne, ben, une fois, c'est bien, il faut se défendre deux fois, cinq fois, dix fois.
Ils ont les moyens de le faire. C'est un exemple théorique.
Ouais.
Ils ont les moyens de le faire. Ça s'appelle une procédure-bâillon parce qu'à terme, on aura bâillonné toute la parole sur ces sujets-là.
Ouais, ouais. Et—
Donc à ça, il faut qu'on soit vraiment attentif parce que ces,
ces procédures-bâillons, ben, c'est prévu dans aucun texte, évidemment, mais ce sont des pratiques qui se mettent en place et qui sont possibles parce que les journalistes parlent de puissance économique
et qu'à terme, si on met pas en place les moyens de les défendre, eh bien, ils n'en parleront plus.
Ouais. Mais oui, mais du coup, la question semble évidente. Qu'est-ce que l'AJP peut faire face à ça ?
Alors,
nous, quand un journaliste,
fait l'objet d'une série d'actions judiciaires, comme par exemple David Leloup, pour l'instant, hein, qui est un journaliste indépendant qui écrit dans « Le Vif
», fait l'objet de quatre à cinq actions, soit devant le Conseil de déontologie, soit en justice,
par Ogeo, par Netis, par toute cette galaxie-là.
Donc, ce qu'on fait par rapport à David Leloup, c'est qu'on a mis à sa disposition un avocat, parce que si lui-même devait se défendre en payant un avocat pour tous ces dossiers, je pense qu'il y a longtemps qu'il aurait jeté l'éponge.
Donc, on met à disposition un avocat, un bon avocat, spécialisé. On fait en sorte de suivre les dossiers. Et puis, on utilise aussi l'opinion publique.
Parce que comme il s'agit pour nous de procédures qui, à terme, visent à bâillonner David Leloup ou Le Vif à propos de ces sujets-là,
on a, avec la Fédération européenne des journalistes, et c'est la Fédération qui a pris l'initiative, dénoncé cet état de, enfin ces procédures devant le Conseil de l'Europe.
Le Conseil de l'Europe, il a une plateforme qui vise en fait à recueillir toutes les violations à la liberté d'expression en Europe, Europe au sens du Conseil de l'Europe, donc Grande Europe.
Et le Conseil de l'Europe liste ces violations-là et au-delà de les lister, demande à l'État qui est concerné de venir s'expliquer.
Autrement dit, la Belgique doit venir s'expliquer à propos des procédures-bâillons qui touchent David Leloup.
Donc ça, évidemment, pour un État, c'est un peu plus gênant que la petite union professionnelle qui va juste mettre à disposition un avocat.
Donc ce qu'on fait, en fait, on utilise tous les leviers qui sont à notre disposition pour faire en sorte que les journalistes puissent continuer à faire leur métier.
Maintenant, en fonction de ce qu'on a en face, on s'adapte aussi.
Martine, merci beaucoup d'avoir passé Septante Minutes Avec moi. On a un petit peu dépassé, mais on fera un petit peu de montage, il y a pas de souci.
Au revoir.
Merci, au revoir.
Voilà, un épisode qui aura été rude à enregistrer pour moi parce que j'étais loin d'être au top de ma forme. Mais du coup, j'ai à présent une bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle à vous annoncer.
La mauvaise nouvelle, c'est que Septante Minutes Avec s'arrête pour cette saison. Je vais faire une petite pause. Et du coup, cet été aura été, ben ouais, assez pauvre en épisodes.
Finalement, j'en ai sorti un en juillet et un en août. Comme je le disais, les gens sont pas trop dispo en ce moment. J'ai des choses à gérer de mon côté aussi.
Et si en plus, Fanny Ruwet me contaminait avec ses microbes, ça va vraiment pas le faire. Mais la bonne nouvelle, c'est qu'il y a plein d'invités super intéressants qui arrivent bientôt.
Du coup, je vous en dis pas plus pour l'instant, mais je suis chaud bouillant. La saison 2 commencera en septembre.
Je ferai peut-être un épisode spécial avec juste moi pour en parler. Je ne sais pas, on verra. Si vous avez des questions à propos du podcast, à propos de moi, si vous avez des suggestions d'invités, comme d'habitude, n'hésitez pas.
Tous les liens vers les réseaux sociaux sont dans la description. Et avant de se dire au revoir et de clôturer cette saison 1, je voulais faire un gros bisou, plein de microbes aux auditeurs.
Vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux, ça fait vraiment plaisir. Et je voulais aussi saluer quelques auditeurs et auditrices en particulier et les remercier, voilà, pour leur fidélité et leur encouragement.
Donc, dans le désordre, il y a Marie-Claire Elderie, Julien Brasseur, Anne Milbodart, Maxime Lempoule, Anne Cauchi, Thomas Dubois, Nicolas Roland, Charlotte Bellière.
Voilà, c'est pas des gens qui m'ont donné de l'argent, c'est juste des gens cool que je voulais remercier parce que voilà, je pense que c'est important.
Voilà, mais on se retrouve dans un mois du coup. Salut !